the guy is still super funny I never met
this woman I never saw this woman this
woman said I met her at the front door
of Bergdorf Goodwin which I rarely go
into other than for a couple of
Charities and a few minutes later we end
up in a a room a dressing room a book of
Goodman right near the cash register
what kind of a woman meets somebody and
brings them up and within minutes you're
playing hanky-panky in a dressing room
okay Trump obviously has engaged in
hyperbole exaggeration let's say a
little bending of the truth every now
and again and he was a billionaire
playboy for a long time but at the end
there when he says listen to me I swear
on my children and I never do that I
have no idea who this woman is I this
did not happen one feels that that is
sincere and he's funny the whole time
it's the only way to deflate this